bien mes chers collègues nous allons
débuter bien le bonjour on vous laisse
vous installer voilà mes chers collègues
donc nous allons entendre ce matin
Monsieur Jean Lessy qui est candidat
proposé par le Président de la
République par le Président de la Haute
Autorité de Santé pardon peut-être un J
de la républque Autorité de Santé au
fonction de directeur général de cette
même autorité en application de
l'article L
14511 du code de la santé publique sa
nomination doit être précéd de son
audition par les commissions compétentes
du Parlement sans que celle-ci soit
suivie d'un vote donc là ce matin il n'y
a pas de vote je vous précise que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et qui sera
consultable en vidéo à la demande je
vous précise également que vous
trouverez le CV de Monsieur dans dém
maintenant vous êtes habitué à
l'utilisation de démire j'indiquerai
simplement qu'il a débuté sa carrière au
sein de l'administration du Sénat et
qu'il était jusqu'à cette année ah
pardon
excusez-moi
d'accord bon j'ai un problème de phrase
bon très
concrètement je vous rappelle simplement
que la Autorité de Santé est une
autorité publique indépendante à
caractère scientifique ses missions sont
fix
donc à l'article L11 37 du code de la
sécurité sociale elle est ainsi
principalement chargée d'évaluer les
médicaments les dispositifs médicaux et
les actes professionnels en vue de le
remboursement de recommander les bonnes
pratiques professionnelles ainsi que
d'élaborer des recommandations
vaccinales et de santé publique et enfin
de mesurer et d'améliorer la qualité
dans les hôpitaux clinique en médecine
de ville et dans les structures sociales
et médicosociales elle occupe donc une
position imp important dans le paysage
institutionnel de la santé en France
nous avons souvent l'occasion de faire
référence à la HAS et l'actualité des
derniers mois nous a montré justement le
rôle essentiel de la CHS dans notre
organisation en matière de santé pour
commencer monsieur lesess je vais vous
laisse je vais vous laisser le soin de
vous présenter de nous expliquer ce qui
vous conduit aujourd'hui à vous porter
candidat à l'exercice des fonctions de
directeur général de la HAS je vous
propose de nous indiquer en suivant quel
serait le cas échant vos priorités
d'action ce qui pour nous essentiel sur
ce dernier point vous pourriez notamment
nous donner votre vision sur un sujet
dont nous sommes parfois saisis par des
patientsou des associations à savoir les
délais d'accès à certains médicaments
innovants notamment ceux qui visent
certains type de cancer rare pour lequel
il est difficile d'avoir des Cortes
suffisantes pour l'obtention de preuves
dans le cadre des essaiis cliniques la
méthodologie de la HS peut-elle selon
vous être adaptée à cette nouvelle
thérapie de précision dont la part
àocation à croîre à l'avenir voilà les
membres de la commission vont vous
entendre après vos propos liminires puis
nous donnerons la parole à nos
rapporteurs notre rapporteur général du
budget puis à notre rapporteur de la
branche maladie et ensuite tous les
sénateurs qui souhaiteront pourront
intervenir à l'issu voilà je vous laisse
maintenant la parole merci
beaucoup merci Monsieur le le président
donc en une dizaine de minutes je vais
essayer de vous présenter c'est d'abord
rapidement mon mon parcours le contexte
de la ha Autorité de Santé aujourd'hui
et les la manière dont je me projette
dans cette fonction directeur général
étant précisé que je n'occupe pas le
poste actuellement et donc ce sera voilà
avec une toute une humilité toute
particulière que je vous en parlerai je
vous remercie monsieur le Président pour
vos propos liminires et je dois vous
dire je suis très honoré cont tenu aussi
des missions que vous avez rappelé de la
HAS d'être devant vous ce matin sur ce
sur ce sujet alors sur mon parcours en
trois composantes donc la première n'est
pas malheureusement le le Sénat euh la
première composante nous verrons c'est
c'est le Conseil d'État où j'ai exercé
l'essentiel de mes de mes fonctions
jusqu'à présent du côté consultatif
comme du côté contentieux et je dois
vous dire que par rapport à la HS et aux
fonctions auxquelles je je je me
présente j'en retire deux éléments
importants de méthodes de conviction
très importantes la première
culturellement pour moi
professionnellement la collégialité est
quelque chose de décisif la
contradiction des points de vue euh
constructive c'est la clé de la qualité
de la décision de justice rendue c'est
la qualité de l' viis rendue qui est en
jeu donc ça c'est un élément important
et je crois que ça vaut dans de nombreux
contextes deuxième conviction que je
retire sur ce qu l'indépendance
l'indépendance c'est quelque chose
d'individuel c'estindépendance d'esprit
qui doit être celle de tout agent public
pour innover bon mais dans un contexte
que ce soit juridictionnel ou à la
Autorité de Santé l'indépendance
institutionnel ça veut dire que
l'autorité dit ce qu'elle a à dire elle
dit ce qu'elle a à dire en droit au
Conseil d'État
en en
science à has mais elle le fait en
écoutant toutes les parties prenantes en
étant attentive aussi en terme d'agenda
de calendrier de ses travaux à la marche
de la société deuxème composante de ma
carrière ce sont les sujets sanitaires
et sociaux au Conseil d'État j'ai été
affecté côté contentieux côté
consultatif dans les chambres
compétentes sur le champ social donc à
la première chambre du contentieux où
j'ai été rapporteur au rapporteur public
de nombreux dossiers sur le prix du
médicament Miss remboursement deel tel
médicament sur des autorisations de mise
sur le marché la tarification des éepad
ou des établissements de santé et et
bien d'autres encore côté consultatif à
la section sociale j'ai été rapporteur
de projet de loi d'ordonnance ou décret
dans dans ces matières également
quelques exemples j'ai rapporté de
nombreux projet de loi d'urgence
sanitaire ces trois dernières années
j'ai été rapporteur général du pfss 2024
récemment ou de d'autres d'autres textes
encore alors de ces de ces fonds
fonction sur les sujets sanitaires et
sociaux je ne retire pas la qualité
d'expert aujourd'hui des sujets de la
Haute Autorité de santé mais une vision
global de ce champ où il y a de
nombreuses résonances de nombreuses
échos qui sont importants dans
l'émission de la HS je pense notamment
aux résonance entre le secteur sanitaire
et médico-social qui sont toutes les
deux dans le champ de la de
laahas troème composante de mon parcours
ça a été mes fonctions de secrétaire
général de la knil entre 2017 et 2020
alors pour les est situé le secrétaire
général de la knil c'est un
positionnement tout à fait comparable
dans des missions différentes à celui de
directeur général de la HAS il y a une
présidente exécutive à laaknil sous
l'autorité de laquelle le secrétaire
général dirige l'activité de l'ensemble
des services il assure le fonctionnement
du collège que préside aussi la la
Présidente il garantit l'indépendance de
l'institution qu'il représente aussi à
l'extérieur et notamment dans de
nombreuses auditions au au Parlement
donc un contexte un schéma
institutionnel assez comparable mais
dans des missions distinctes le deuxième
élément que je retire de mon expérience
l'acnil ça a été évidemment une
immersion dans les sujets numériques et
de protection des données de manière
générale jeux pas vous en parler mais en
particulier dans le champ de la santé
qui était en haut de l'agenda de laacnil
on avait les enjeux de la création de la
plateforme des données de santé le
health data hub de l'extension du snds
de la constitution des entrepôt de
données de santé notamment de données
cliniques d'origine hospitalière les
objets connectés en santé tout tout ce
qui changer voilà technologiquement et
en terme d'usage en lien avec le
numérique en santé et ce sont des sujets
importants pour le système de santé et
important bien entendu dans l'mission de
la Haute Autorité de santé et la
troisième chose que que j'en retire
aussi et qui était vraiment intéressant
humainement c'est du management de
l'autorité et du management d'experts en
particulier des experts juridiques je
connaissais un peu des experts aussi
technologiques je le connaissais
beaucoup moins de des des ingénieurs
informatiques des auditeurs de systèmes
d'inform formation et c'était
intéressant de dialoguer avec des corps
de métiers différents de de ma formation
et de les faire dialoguer entre eux pour
à la fin produire une décision si
possible claire et opérationnelle donc
voilà sur sur sur mon parcours sur la HS
aujourd'hui alors je rappellerai pas
lesmion le trépied d'émission vous
l'avez fait monsieur le Président le fil
rouge de ces trois missions hein
l'évaluation des technologies de santé
les recommandations de bonnes pratiqu ou
de santé publique et la mesure de la
qualité par des indicateurs ou
différents processus de certification ou
d'accréditation je pourrais revenir le
fil rouge c'est la régulation du système
de santé par la qualité et l'efficience
l'HS elle délivre une
expertise médicotechnique médicale
médico-économique pour qu'ensuite les
décideurs les payeurs l'état l'assurance
maladie les professionnels de santé des
patients sachent quels sont les soins
les les les les les les thérapies les
actes utiles qui qui pevent être prise
en charge près la solidarité nationale
si oui à quel niveau ça c'est pour les
pouvoirs publics et puis dans la
pratique professionnelle quelles sont
les bonnes pratiques recommandées en
l'état de l'art au vu des données
acquises de la de la science donc ça
c'est le trépied ce que je voulais
souligner peut-être en plus monsieur le
Président c'est la dynamique qui a connu
ce trépied
euh quand on regarde 20 ans en arrière
création de la HAS 2004 les missions se
sont démultiplié l'article
l161-37 vous l'avez rappelé qui est le
la l'émission de la HS il a été modifié
31 fois depuis 2004 donc c'est une
preuve de la confiance je peux l'espérer
du législateur dans la Haute Autorité
c'est aussi un symptôme du besoin
d'expertise scientifique pour décider ou
pratiquer en en santé mais cette
densification elle se traduit aussi de
deux autres manières je dirais à mission
presque mission constante d'abord c'est
le puissant mouvement vous y avez fait
allusion de de l'innovation en
santé les progrès thérapeutiques les
progrès aussi diagnostiques les
innovations organisationnelles avec le
le numérique tout ceci ça crée des
nouvelles compétences pour la HS en
matière de télésurveillance d'actes
innovant de de biologie de dispositif
numérique thérapeutique ça crée aussi am
mission constante des un besoin
d'innover dans la manière d'exercer les
les missions et puis deuxième mouvement
qui a densifié ces missions c'est
l'évolution de la demande sociale ou des
attentes des besoins de la société en
dans champ sanitaire et
médico-social le contexte vous le
connaissez le vieillissement
démographique la prévalence des maladies
chroniques la notion de parcours de de
santé qui est importante également les
enjeux de démographie professionnelle
l'état de l'hôpital la qualité de vie
des des soignants de manière générale et
de la démographie libérale bien entendu
aussi le la la la montée en puissance
des droits des patients juridiquement
mais aussi en terme de revendication les
patients demandent à évidemment exercer
leur aut détermination en santé plus
qu'avance qui est un bon mouvement bien
entendu mais qui doit être intégré par
les pouvoirs publics dans leur dans leur
action et de nombreux autres changements
qui au final se traduisent au niveau de
la HAS par de nouvelles sollicitations
légitimes alors par rapport à ces défis
donc justement je vous réponds monsieur
le Président mais je commence à répondre
je pense qu'il y aura peut-être d'autres
questions euh les les orientation
stratégique elles se elles sont définies
aujourd'hui dans une feuille de route
stratégique qui s'achève en 2023 et la
HS va réécrire écrire plutôt une
nouvelle stratégie plurriannuelle à
partir de 2024 Lionel colollé a lors de
ces auditions déjà fait part de
plusieurs orientations qui lui tenaient
particulièrement à cœur et que je
rappelle d'abord un axe très important
sur la place des usagers les usagers ils
sont déjà présents dans les travaux de
la HS dans ces groupes de travail dans
un conseil de l'engagement des usagers
dans le contenu de ces recommandations
je pourrais revenir si si vous voulez il
y a un besoin tellement fort aussi de
confiance en en l'expertise qu'il faut
aller encore encore plus loin deuxème
priorité sur l'impact des
recommandations sur l'impact de la
parole de la Haute Autorité de Santé
euh lautoré de santé je crois fait des
travaux de qualité qui sont reconnus
mais il faut évidemment que ces travaux
arrivent soi lu soi intégrés dans les
pratiques professionnelles c'est un défi
complémentaire mais distinct sur
lequelle la Haute Autorité a déjà
travaillé et qui est une des clés de des
des prochaines années un élément aussi j
viens d'efficacité d'efficacité
administrative vous avez mentionné
l'enjeu majeur des délais de mise à
disposition des innovations l'innovation
c'est bien c'est quand elle arrive
auprès des patients qu'elle a été
évaluée et qu'on sait que c'est une
vraie innovation qu'elle apporte quelque
chose que le changement se fait
évidemment pour la vie des patients et
pour aussi la santé publique dans
certains cas par rapport à ça il y a il
y a deux deux sujets euh al je sais pas
si approfondi maintenant ou après il y a
la question des délais de la Haute
Autorité de santé des services de la
Commission de la transparence en terme
de délai objectivement il faut pouvoir
sur certains points aller plus vite
qu'aujourd'hui le président lonal cy l'a
dit il faut aussi quand on se compare au
niveau européen voir que la France n'est
et la Autorité de santé en particulier
ne sont pas en si mauvaise position que
ça en terme de délai notamment quand on
intègre les nouvelle procédure d'accès
rapide notamment l'accès précoce par que
que ce soit un accès de droit commun ou
un accès précoce l'essentiel c'est que
le patient qui en a besoin qui en a pas
thérapeutique puisse accéder à à la
molécule l'accès précoce c'est une
excellente mesure ça fait 2 ans que
c'est c'est en place si on les intègre
dans les délais c'est c'est plutôt
rassurant très rassurant même en
comparaison européenne mais comparaison
n'est pas raison combi même seraiit-on
les meilleurs si c'est pas assez bien il
faut continuer à faire mieux donc c'est
un sujet évidemment important je
pourrais y revenir il y a la question
des délais il y a la question aussi dans
ce que vous avez dit monsieur le
Président de la comp par raison du
comparateur avec le problème de ces
médicaments notamment en matière
d'oncologie de maladies rares pour
lesquels on a pas de comparateur or
l'évaluation c'est comparé pour
notamment savoir s'il y a amélioration
du service médical rendu c'estàd c'est
une valeur ajoutée de ce qui arrive bon
pour fixer son prix pour l'inscrire sur
les list enu à l'hôpital et là en effet
il y a une question méthodologique je
pourrais y revenir la Commission de la
transparence de la hasas elle a déjà
fait évoluer sa doctrine en mars 2023 la
CHS réfléchit de manière continue à
cette problématique à sa doctrine est-ce
qu'il faudra de nouvelles évolutions là
c'est pas ni au futur DG ni au DG actuel
si je l'étais de vous répondre en
revanche de vous dire que le sujet est à
l'agenda et qu'on s'organise en interne
au niveau des services pour appuyer la
Commission de la transparence dans sa
réflexion ça je vous le
garantis donc pour terminer par que j'ai
répondu à vos questions sur les la
manière dont je me projet dans les
fonctions de directeur général elle-même
qui ne sont pas celles de président ou
de membres du collège euh pour moi il y
a quatre
priorités des priorités managériales
bien entendu d'abord une question de un
enjeu de cohésion le directeur général
c'est celui qui garantit que l'équipe
est soudée et qu'elle avance au service
du projet stratégique et des attentes
des pouvoirs publics et de la société
garantir la cohésion là-dessus j'arrive
dans un terrain qui a déjà du des
facteurs de cohésion très fort ce sont
les valeurs de l'achs que je rappelle
ils sont importants la
rigueur la transparence l'indépendance
et par rapport à tous les enjeux aussi
d'accélération des délais il faudra
toujours en revenir aussi à ces valeurs
essentielles j'ajoute aussi ce qui donne
du sens au quotidien c'est le sens du
service public et la CHS l'a déjà et j'y
arriverai avec personnellement une
volonté de service de service public
très très prononcée deuxième priorité et
elle est importante en termes
managériaux mais aussi de qualité de la
production c'est la
transversalité vous avez rappelé lesé
mississions monsieur le Président les
trois grandes missions le fil rouge la
qualité tout se tient donc il faut
travailler en transversalité la HS le
fait déjà c'est important aussi
non seulement parce qu'il a un fil rouge
unique c'est important en terme de
motivation pour les agents c'est
important en terme de captation du réel
la transversalité ça veut dire quoi que
si quelque part la HS cap dans dans son
organigramme un signal faible ou fort
d'une problématique que ça puiss
irriguer les autres missions de la de
l'autorité c'est un gage d'amélioration
des pratiques un gage d'adhérence sur le
réel trème chose suraspect managérial
les
moyens le Parlement a donné à la ch pour
2024 les moyens de fonctionner avec
notamment le le rebasage de la dotation
de l'Assurance Maladie bon donc l' HS a
les moyens de
fonctionner la question se pose aussi de
des troupes des ETP est-ce qu'elle a les
moyens humains pour fonctionner le
plafond d'emploi a été relevé on peut
remercier le Parlement de 438 à 443 ETP
au vu de l'ensemble de toutes les
nouvelles mission j'aurais besoin de de
faire le point sur ce sujet dans un
contexte lané très très contraint
dernière priorité et qui concerne aussi
le Parlement pour moi ça sera de
garantir l'ouverture de la HS elle est
indépendante ça veut pas dire qu'elle
est fermée au contraire l'indépendance
c'est la force qui permet d'être ouvert
et de parler à tout le monde donc je
j'en seraai garant à mon niveau dans
dans mes fonction sous l'autorité du
président ouverture envers tous les
partenaires de l'administration ou de la
sphère publique les agences sanitaires
les conseils départementaux pour les
aspects médicau-sociaux les ARS aussi
les ministères bien entend et le
ministère de la Santé au au premier chef
le Parlement c'est une logique
institutionnelle de d'avoir une relation
de confiance avec le Parlement c'est une
logique d'efficacité tout simplement
pour la HAS d'être de garantir son
contact avec les attentes de la de la
société et puis un dernier point plus
personnel pour terminer sur cette
dimension ouverture je crois que nous
avons tous institution publique une
question un enjeu c'est la défiance le
risque de défiance ou la défiance réelle
des citoyens dans l'action publique elle
a pu se manifester récemment vis-àvis
d'expertise en santé c'est pas un sujet
propre à l'expertise de la hsexertise en
santé en particulier hein c'est commun
de nombreuses formes d'expertise c'est
un défi auquel la CHS doit travailler
pour ce qui la concerne et ça ne pourra
voilà qu'être pour moi un sujet
d'intérêt particulier je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
pour ces propos je donne tout de suite
la parole à Isabelle douanau notre
rapporteur général merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur et chers
collègues je voudrais tout d'abord vous
remercier pour votre exposé qui était
tout à fait comment éclairant sur d'une
part votre parcours et sur l'idée que
vous faites de la direction générale de
la Haute Autorité de Santé euh en en
réalité je crois que vous réunissez
effectivement un certain nombre de
compétences que vous avez acquises dans
vos différentes fonctions et vous
semblez le candidat idéal maintenant euh
euh j'aimerais aussi vous découvrir un
peu plus parce que je pense que quand on
se se euh présente pour une direction
euh il faut aussi euh entendre qu' qu'
qu'il y ait une forte connivance en
quelque sorte avec le président ou la
présidente existante je pense que
fabiene Bartoli avait dans son temps
auprès de Dominique leuludec auprès de
Lionel Collet aussi eu ce ce principe
d'avancer comme un binôme c'est-à-dire
vraiment euh respectueux du rôle de
chacun parce que ça c'est très très
important entre président et directeur
général donc avancer avec le rôle
respecter de chacun et puis aussi mettre
en œuvre en fait ce qu'attendent les
Français en terme de de sécurité donc ça
je voulais euh voilà connaître un petit
peu votre avis enfin en tout cas votre
positionnement par rapport au président
ensuite j'ai deux questions vous avez
parlé effectivement euh de l'implication
des patients
aujourd'hui dans notre système de santé
il y a une très très forte demande ça
vous avez insisté là-dessus et je suis
totalement d'accord avec vous euh mais
comment associer ceux qui sont les plus
finalement qui ont le plus envie parce
que quelquefois il y a des
revendications mais ces mêmes personnes
on n'arrive pas forcément à les inclure
dans un programme et comment entraîner
en fait ceux qui ont vraiment envie de
participer à à l'écriture en tout cas
des règlements ou des nouvelles mesures
ou finalement un certain nombre de de
points qui concernent les patients et je
pense notamment à l'outil e Satis Isatis
he qui sur l'expérience patient ou la
représentant ou la représentation des
usagers dans ces diverses commissions
quel comment vous voyez c'est ces
élémentsl comment organiser le l'idée du
du patient expertin et puis au-delà du
patient expert c'est aussi la famille
experte parce que on pense toujours au
patients mais il y a aussi la famille
qui tient un rôle
particulier donc finalement quel regard
vous portez sur cette demande
d'association plus forte et
l'insatisfaction persistante des
représentants des usagers concernant le
rôle dans le système de santé comment la
Haute Autorité de Santé doit-elle selon
vous contribuer à soutenir l'engagement
des usagers la deuxième question c'est
sur en fait le glissement de compétences
de de professionnels de santé pendant
euh toutes ces dernières années nous
avons cherché pour euh essayer de
combler le problème d'accès aux
soins nous avons essayé en tout cas de
répartir les responsabilités et les
soins sur les différents professionnels
de santé quel est aussi votre point de
vue sur cette recherche de de
l'efficience à travers le partage des
compétences et la délégation de de
tâches quel regard vous portez en
général sur ces évolutions et quelle
contribution la Haute Autorité peut-elle
selon vous y apporter des les priorités
doivent-elles selon vous être identifié
en la matière je vous remercie je vous
laisse répondre à notre rapporteur
général merci Monsieur président merci
Madame la rapporteur générale pour ces
ces
questions je réponds dans l'ordre sur le
le rapport avec le le président moi il y
a un seul mot qui me vient à l'esprit
qui est de déontologie c'est la loyauté
elle doit être totale la loyauté pour
moi ça veut dire deux choses d'abord
qu'entre quatre yeux le dialogue est
très franc on doit tout pouvoir se dire
euh pour que justement le binôme soit
plus fort qu'en revanche en dehors de ce
colloc singulier si jeose dire euh entre
le directeur général et son président
euh l'institution n'a qu'une seule tête
voilà c'est le président et le directeur
général est là auprès du président sous
son autorité comme je l'ai souligné dans
l'ensemble de ses missions donc ça c'est
le la réponse euh on dire déontologique
sur la loyauté après en terme pratique
je suppose qu'il y aura une réparation
des tâches j'ai connu ce positionnement
à l'acnil où il était vraiment identique
et ça s'est très très bien passé et
voilà
loyauté complète ce qui n'exclut pas
évidemment qu'il puisse y avoir des
échanges mais ces échanges doivent être
dans le dans le à l'intérieur du
binô sur alors l'implication des
patients en effet j'en ai parlé parce
que je crois comme vous que c'est
nécessaire en terme d'efficacité du
système de santé en terme de confiance
aussi voilà je vous ai dit de je vous ai
parlé du sujet de la défiance alors sur
le patient expert je crois que la HS
reconnaît depuis des années et Lionel
col est particulièrement attaché que les
savoirs expérientiels l'expérience du
patient c'est une expertise les
représentants des associations sont
présents dans les instances en tant
qu'expert voilà c'est pas des
experts d'un domaine particulier de ils
sont experts de leur savoir de leur
expérience donc c'est en effet une vraie
une vraie expertise après il y a des
axes de progrès la HS y a travaillé ces
dernières années dans le cadre d'une
commission spécifique elle a créé une
commission pour réfléchir à alors à à à
l'engagement des usagers c'est le
conseil de l'engagement des usagés qui
est une commission permanente cré en
2019 je je crois et cette commission ce
conseil pardon a rendu très récemment un
rapport avec des pistes pour aller plus
loin aller plus loin dans l'effectivité
des droits individuels des patients dans
la représentation aussi collective des
patients parce qu'on on voit bien qu'en
effet euh le on a des droits qui sont
consacrés et la France est assez
pionnière mais qui sont pas complètement
effectifs et on a des droits collectifs
qui là aussi euh sont sont incarné dans
des processus dans des dans dans une
comitologie mais qui laisse une certaine
insatisfaction par rapport au poids par
numérique des représentants
d'association dans les dans les
enceintes soit hospitalières soit
médico-sociales qui leur sont dédié ça
peut créer une forme de frustration ça
peut créer aussi un problème à trouver
des vocations voilà pour siéger tout
simplement dans dans dans ces instances
donc oui il y a il y a un axe de travail
euh moi là ce qui me rassure c'est qu'un
diagnostic a été posé récemment
évidemment applique maintenant
d'appliquer une feuille de
route euh sur le les les compétences
entre professionnelles de santé c'est
vrai qu'il y a il y a il y a il y a des
enjeux de délégation de tâche il y a
plus généralement des enjeux de partage
de partage de responsabilité avec des
des frontières que qui sont redessinées
fréquemment ces derniers temps et de
manière intéressante je renvoie à la à
la loi récente qui est issue d'une
PPL sur la la confiance en en santé qui
a introduit de nouvelles formes de
partage de responsabilité dans la
pratique avancée des infirmiers
pratiques avancé l'accès direct la
question de l'accès direct au massur
kinési thérapeute donc tout ceci c'est
en effet un sujet pour la HS parce que
le seul la seule boussole c'est la
qualité donc la HS elle est amenée à
rendre des avis sur les conditions de
prise en charge de certaines de ces de
ces de ces actes de certains de ces
actes elle est conduite aussi évidemment
à les intégrer dans ces recommandations
de bonnes pratique professionnelles
c'est une des évolution de
l'environnement ce nouveau partage de
responsabilité il est très intéressant
pour répondre aux enjeux de de
démographie même s'il n'est pas lui seul
la solution bien entendu et l' HS va
l'appréhender l'appréhende déjà sous l'
de la qualité et je crois quand même on
peut être assez confiant sur la
possibilité d'avoir des soins de qualité
avec un nouveau partage ça sera motivant
d'ailleurs aussi pour tous les acteurs
tous les acteur
impliqués merci beaucoup monsieur luessy
je donne maintenant la parole à
corinebert qui est rapporteur de la
branche maladie merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur pour pour votre
exposé et et vos premières réponses aux
questions de la rapporteur générale
j'auris quant à
moi quelques questions également euh
tout d'abord
avec le contexte sanitaire que l'on
connaît et plus particulièrement la
crise du de la covid-19 je reviens un
petit peu en arrière celle-ci a rappelé
la nécessité pour les autorités
sanitaires de se préparer agir en
situation de crise et et et donc
d'anticiper quels enseignements la Haute
Autorité doit-elle selon vous tirer de
cette expérience et et comment son
organisation peut-elle s'adapter pour
gérer la la survenue de nouveaux de
nouveaux épisodes de crise
pour revenir à une actualité plus
récente
euh à l'occasion de de de l'audition
relative au projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2024 donc
sujet que vous connaissez bien puisque
vous avez été rapporteur dans les
fonctions que que vous occupiez jusqu'à
présent le président et la directrice de
la HS ont évoqué la forte augmentation
du nombre de de vaccin entrant sur le
marché ce qui tendait à à allonger les
délais d'accès pour les patients en
raison du temps préalable d'évaluation
et vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
dans vos propos la question des euh
délais
euh donc euh le président et la
direction de la directrice générale
avaiit lors de ses auditions exprimé
cette préoccupation euh quant aux moyens
dédiés à ces missions d'évaluation euh
en gardant l'objectif d'une stratégie
vaccinale sécurisée parce que derrière
ces questionsl et le sujet des vaccins
est pas anodin évidemment c'est la la la
la stratégie vaccinale efficace et les
enjeux euh autour de la réactivité de la
hasas quelle est votre appréciation
quant à vous alors j'imagine que vous
vous évoquez les les délais c'était pas
c'était pas anodin et comment
entendez-vous y faire face
euh autre mission de la HS c'est la
certification des établissements de
santé hein qu'elle assume elle-même euh
dont elle a elle a fait évoluer ses
procédures parce que effffectivement ça
c'était euh une charge administrative
excessive en tout cas jugé comme telle
pour les les état éblissement pour les
les équipes soignantes qui sont déjà
fortement mobilisées quel regard
portez-vous sur la la conduite de la
démarche de certification et quelles
améliorations voyez-vous encore à mettre
en
œuvre toujours sur la question des des
hôpitaux avec la la le nouveau modèle de
financement du champ MCO médecine
chirurgie obostétrique qui prévoit une
refondte du dispositif dit IFAC
l'incitation financière à la qualité
comment les visites d'inspection de la
HS peuvent-elles selon vous partir à
mieux valoriser la qualité dans les
hôpitaux enfin de deux petites questions
qui me sont venues aussi en vous
écoutant vous parliez d'ouverture tout à
l'heure
euh comment voyez-vous vos relations de
de travail enfin vos relation tout
simplement avec l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et et enfin je
m'en arrêterai là la HS a déjà fait
évoluer par le passé ses outils euh
incluant l'arrivée de l'intelligence
artificielle
euh comment de votre point de vue en
tout cas la HS doit-elle continuer à
travailler sur ces questionsl et
notamment sur l'impact de l'intelligence
artificielle sur la prise en charge des
patients je vous remercie merci Monsieur
less je laisse
répondre merci pour ces merci pour pour
ces
questions sur peut-êre par la dernière
parce que j'ai omis de répondre sur un
point aux questions précédentes c'est
euh le les les les outils d'intelligence
artificielle alors l'intelligence
artificielle elle se c'est c'est
vraiment c'est une révolution inoui et
on en est qu'au début euh dans notre
notre mode de vie et dans le système de
de santé en en particulier alors
l'intelligence artificielle elle va en
fait impacter le la la la santé dans le
champ HS à plusieurs niveaux elle va
changer man man de faire les essais
cliniques en avant en amont de la
commercialisation des médicaments et
donc dans ce qui va nous arriver en
terme d'évaluation du médicament on a eu
l'utilisation de de l'IA l'IA elle
pourra être embarquée dans des
dispositifs médicaux alors soit des
dispositifs médicaux purement
professionnels he des logiciels d'aide
au diagnostic soit dans certains disposi
médicaux mis à disposition des des
patients
elle pourra aussi être un outil pour la
Haute Autorité de Santé pour mieux
exercer ses mission et je prends deux
exemples par rapport par rapport à ça
c'est d'abord sur le suivi des
recommandations dans quelle mesure elles
sont suivies par les les les
professionnels on a fait je crois
quelques quelques expérimentations
récentes par exemple sur l'épilepsie
pour mesurer en allant regarder dans les
bases de données dans quelle mesure le
schéma de parcours le parcours
recommandé par l'autorité de santé était
suivi dans les faits et de voir les les
écarts donc premier usage deuxième usage
c'est Isatis justement les patients
remplissent à la sortie de l'hôpital
voilà un questionnaire alors il y a des
questions binaires bon il a des
questions champ libre l'exploitation du
champ libre quand vous avez plus d'un
million de questionnaires qui remontent
chaque année euh sauf à dédier 300 TP au
sujet ce que je ne demande pas voilà
l'exploitation des Champs Libres c'est
quelque chose de très délicat et
l'intelligence artificielle aide à ça
donc depuis quelques mois euh laahs a
testé l'utilisation d'un outil dia pour
exploiter les commentaires de champ
libre qui sont extrêmement précieux
parce que c'est là que les patients bah
s'expriment avec leurs mots disent ce
qui ce qui a été ce qui a compté surtout
pour eux au-delà des cases qu'ils ont
coché ou pas au au-dessus et ça donnait
des résultats extrêmement intéressants
donc oui c'est aussi un outil de de
prise en compte de l'humain voilà
c'est-à-dire de l'expérience patient la
plus la plus qualitative euh sur le donc
je reprends dans l'ordre le la covid-19
et la nécessité de se préparer
c'est cette cette crise à a bouleversé
nos nos organisations qui en est dont on
s'est rendu compte qu'elle n'était en
partie pas préparé et pas seulement dans
ch de la santé c'est une problématique
plus plus générale vous avez raison de
de le souligner la HS y a consacré son
rapport prospectif 2022 donc c'est c'est
il y a une centaine de pages après
plusieurs dizaines d'auditions donc des
pages très très nourres sur justement
comment faire mieux la prochaine fois si
prochaine fois devait y avoir j'en
retiens juste un élément deux éléments
importants
d'abord pour être efficace en temps de
crise faut se préparer hors crise il
faut se préparer aussi de manière
partenariale c'est tout ce qu'on fait en
terme d'ouverture de partenariat
d'interaction avec la NSM avec santé
publique France avec aussi les réseaux
de collectivité je vous parlais tout à
l'heure des conseil département dans ch
médicosociale tout ce qu'on fait en en
temps ordinaire pour mieux dialoguer
pour mieux interroger pour avoir
confiance benah ça aide au moment de la
crise parce Queau moment de la crise
quand on arrive pas à se parler c'est
souvent qu'on se parlait pas bien avant
donc leur crise est très important euh
il est important aussi pour
prépositionner des éléments spécifiques
à la crise euh des systèmes
d'information qui seront utilisés en
temps de crise sur évidemment des des
des notamment des données
épidémiologiques euh l'utilisation des
bases
médicau-administratives en en temps de
crise qu'on puisse voilà se se brancher
avec les modules qui vont bien pour
utiliser à des fins de crise des outils
conçus pour le temps ordinaire ça ça se
prépare en amont et donc il y a un gros
volet gros volet système d'information
puis protocole à mettre en place
l'organisation de temps de crise on
appuie sur un bouton et Tac on crée la
bonne instance de coordination ça si on
l'a pas préparé si on l' pas répété en
temps ordinaire ça marche pas et sur
même en temps de crise quand on appuie
sur le bouton on va découvrir que la
crise n'est pas exactement celle qu'on
avait anticipé mais en tout cas la
culture de la préparation à la crise ça
apportera tout même une partie de la
réponse même s'il faut être modeste
chaque crise sera très différente de
celle qu'on avait préparé et de la
précédente alors sur les les nouveaux
vaccin et la question des des délais là
on a deux deux
objectifs j'ai même trois objectifs
majeurs qui ne se contredisent pas mais
qui doivent être combinés l'objectif
d'abord de rapidité de la mise à
disposition ça vous l'avez dit c'est
c'est nécessaire en terme de santé
publique et des
d'éthique le deuxième enjeu c'est la
qualité parce que si on met à
disposition un vaccin qui soit ne marche
pas soit qui a des effets des effets
indésirables qui non non souhaité non
mesuré à l'avance parce qu'on est allé
trop vite ça va poser des problèmes de
santé et ça va se poser c'est le trè
point problème de conf et on sait que
l'adhésion à la vaccination c'est une
problématique clé pour les années les
années à venir donc voilà voilà un peu
les trois objectifs qu'il faut combiner
donc par rapport à ça oui il faut
pouvoir aller plus vite dans la rigueur
la plus la plus totale c'est un sujet
méthode sujet aussi scientifique moi j'y
serai évidemment attentif pour voir dans
l'organisation interne de la chasse
qu'on peut faire pour aller dans ce sens
le président colé a parfaitement
l'esprit il en avait parlé dans ses dans
ses auditions mais voilà il faut le
faire en essayant de concilier en
essayant en arrivant à concilier ces
trois objectifs que je n'arrive pas à
hiérarchiser entre eux la certification
des établissements de santé
euh vous avez souligné notamment la la
charge pour les soignants et c'est V que
la certification pendant la période de
la covid-19 voilà de de donner lieu à un
ressenti particulier parfois
bon c'est c'est vrai que c'est un sujet
je vous dirais simplement que j'attends
de prendre mon poste pour m' rendre
recomte plus en plus en détail là aussi
il y a deux deux choses à concilier euh
d'abord l'objectif de cette
certification c'est quand même la
qualité en santé qu'attendent les
concitoyens et qu'attendent aussi les
soignants dire c'est c'est le sens aussi
de leur métier que de délivrer des soins
de qualité dans une organisation de
qualité et donc la certification elle
doit être faite et elle doit être amenée
pour venir à l'appui aussi de ce de ce
sens-là et puis y a la question de la
charge que ça prend question de la
charge de la charge que ça induit ça
peut pas ne pas induire de charge
maintenant la certiffiction elle est
faite par des visiteurs des experts
visiteurs qui sont eux-mêmes du monde de
la santé c'est pas moi qui vais j'en
seraai bien incapable
faireext l'expertise au service de la
certification ce sont des professionnels
issu souvent du monde hospitalier pas
assez on pourrait peut-être faire encore
mieux du monde libéral voilà ou des
salariés d'autres d'autres structures
donc voilà c'est des gens qui ont quand
même une sensibilité au sujet qui arrive
il y a une formation qui leur est faite
pour la manière d'arriver pas débarquer
évidemment débarque pas en mode cowboy
voilà mais
évidemment a c'est un métier particulier
ils le font de manière remarquable ils
sont à peu près 800 la communauté des
experts médicaux experts visiteurs il y
a peut-être encore davantag de formation
continue à faire même si les
établissements sont majoritairement
satisfaits de la manière dont ça s'est
passé et donc j'envient à la charge un
des axes c'est que certaines données que
ce soit d'ailleurs indépendable de la
certification pour les indicateurs de
qualité des soins qu'une partie des
données on les extrait directement des
systèmes d'information pour éviter
d'avoir un doublon dans le remplissage
qu'on puisse aller sur le PMSI qu'on
puisse aller sur les les systèmes
d'information des hôpitaux qui sont
malheureusement pas homogènes voilà ou
qu'on puisse aller sur des bases
nationales pour extraire une partie des
données dont on a besoin pour mesurer la
qualité ce qui évite de ressaisir de
doubloner et de prendre du temps à des
gens qui ont en effet autre chose à
faire même si le la qualité ça fait
partie du sens de leur de leur métier et
d'ailleurs quand un établissement est
certifié haute qualité première mention
certification ça crée une fierté ça crée
une fierté pour toutes les équipes voilà
je pense au CHU de Lille récemment ça
crée de la fierté surtout en période de
tension voilà donc il faut là aussi
placer le le
curseur sur les les IFA donc tification
à trois étages voilà qu'introduit le
PLFSS 2024 le financement la quité c'est
très important après c'est une question
de dosage dans la part que ça prend dans
le financement global mais qu'il y ait
du financement à la qualité je crois que
c'est très bien il faut le mesurer avec
les bons indicateurs donc les dotations
IFAC se nourrissent de plusieurs types
d'indicateurs les indicateurs de la CHS
mais pas seulement mais donc les
indicateurs de la CHS les indicateurs
notamment de qualité des des soins vont
venir le panel voilà d'indicateur qui va
permettre de calibrer la la dotation ce
qu'il faut ensuite c'est que la manière
dont la dotation IFAC est calibrée elle
est du sens et la HS a émis des avis
mitigés on va dire euh en 2023 encore
récemment et en
2022 parce que il ne la dotation elle
est fléchée sur les 70 %
d'établissements les
meilleurs on est dans une logique de
concours alors qu'il l' CHS pense qu'il
faait plutôt une logique d'examen
c'est-à-dire que même s'il a plus de 70
% ou moins voilà mais pour que ça ait du
sens c'est laat d'un niveau de qualité
qui doit déclencher l'attribution mais
c'est un sujet complexe c'est un sujet
complexe alors les relations avec l' NSM
je les souhaite les meilleur possible je
je crois qu'elles sont déjà très bonnes
on
a deux points notamment deux points
d'adhérence la dimension effet
indésirable côté ANM qui pour nous ce
sont les enjeux de tolérance par le
patient quand on évalue un médicament
voilà donc la sécurité et l'utilité du
médicament ont évidemment une zone de de
recoupement bien bien entendu et il y a
la question de l'accès précoce qui est
une décision de la HS mais sur conforme
de de la NSM je prends juste cet exemple
là parce que depuis 2 ans ça marche très
bien il y a un travail intégré des
équipes sur l'accès précoce et alors
sans en faire sans extrapoler en disant
que tout va bien j'espère que tout va
bien en tout cas je veillerai ce que
tout aille pour le mieux mais ça marche
très bien il y a pas eu un jour de perdu
à cause de la de la répartition des
tâches entre deux autorités qui ont
quand même à la base des des points
d'attention complémentaire mais très
différents voilà c'est
pas on comprend pourquoi dans la paysage
sanitaire de la France comme dans la
plupart des autres pays une agence
sécurité une agence dédié à la sécurité
à la sécurité c'est une solution quand
même qu'on retrouve à peu près partout
bon pas en Italie mais à peu près à peu
près
partout vu les les enjeux mais en effet
il faut très bien travailler je prendrai
contact dès mon arrivver avec les
services de de la NSM et j'auris accord
vraiment d'avoir des bonnes relations
tout aussi la santé c'est c'est un pack
comme on dira dans certains sports voilà
faut faut avancer vraiment vraiment
ensemble j'en suis
convaincu merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
maintenant je donné la parole à tro de
nos collègues je vais commencer par
Daniel
Chassin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur merci de de vos
propos et de la façon dont vous voyez
votre futur travail avec rigueur
indépendant
qualité si vous nous avez indiqué que
vous allez essayer de d'anticiper de
préparer éventuellement des des crises
qui peuvent qui peuvent arriver ce qui
n'avait pas été tellement le cas au
niveau du du covid moi je poserai une
question uniquement sur le médico-social
où vous avez réfléchi ou travaillé à ce
niveau
là concernant la qualité de de prise en
charge et bonne pratique alors si vous
voulez on va avoir une augmentation très
importante de personnes de plus de 85
ans entre 2020 et 2040 qui vont doubler
et surtout une augmentation très forte
de la dépendance qui va augmenter de de
200000 entre 2020 et de et 2030 donc le
le ce qui est prévu c'est le maintien
domiciliaire c'est-à-dire qu'il fauta
davantage d'emplois pour prendre en
charge les personnes à domicile mais
aussi une augmentation très importante
de la
dépendance en établissement et pour que
une une aide soignante puisse passer au
lieu de 30 minutes passer à 45 minutes
pour la prise en charge d'une personnes
dépendant il faut environ 40000 emplois
c'est 5 emplois de plus par éepad est-ce
que si vous voulez vous allez aller dans
ce sens puisque la loi qui va arriver
uniquement une loi sur bien invveillir
n'apporte pas d'aide spécifique au
niveau emploi mais fait de la de la
prévention et est-ce que vous allez
aller dans ce sens pour 40000 emplois si
vous voulez ce qu'il a un minimum d'ici
2027 pour que et bien on puisse prendre
en charge de façon décente euh nos aînés
dans les épades merci merci beaucoup la
parole à jusine
guidez merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Monsieur le Directeur moi j'ai
été interpellé par comment dire par un
patient atteint de mucovicidose euh et
notamment aussi de pseudoobstruction
esttinale chronique qui sont traité par
la nabulfine et aujourd'hui ce
médicament n'est plus remboursé euh
alors qu'il était remboursé jusqu'à
présent et queon l' s'en sert dans les
hôpitaux pour les enfants donc moi
j'aimerais savoir en s'appuyant sur
quels critères la Haute Autorité de
Santé considère que certains médicaments
ne devrait pas être remboursé par
sécurité sociale et quels sont les
critères et ses outils d'évaluation je
vous remercie merci flan
sasarade merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur merci pour votre
intervention
eu le la maladie d'Alzheimer est une
préoccupation majeure pour notre pays et
entraîne des dépenses
considérables d'une part les les les les
traitements aau donnés euh jusqu'à il y
a peu de temps ont été déremboursé et il
n'y a pas eu d'évaluation de la de
l'arrêt de ces traitements donc je
voudrais savoir ce que vous en pensz et
deuxièmement les États-Unis ont déjà ont
déjà démarré des traitements à base
d'anticorps monoclonaux stit très
efficace avec quelques effets
secondaires à type de micro hémorragie
visible au scanner mais sans sans
manifestation clinique et euh et c'est
un traitement qui doit intervenir tôt
dans la maladie qui débarrasse le
patient de ces plaques amyloïdes sans
for sans forcément le guérir
complètement mais il y a un espoir
considérable là-dessus le le traitement
est de l'ordre de 2000 € par mois
euh et j'ai compris qu'en France on ne
voulait pas pour l'instant se pencher
sur le sujet alors que l'IME est en
train d'évaluer d'évaluer ses produits
donc vu le vu le coûpt d'un
justement du vieillissement de la
maladie d'Alzheimer est-ce qu'on aurait
pas intérêt à anticiper et à
rapidement utiliser ce type de
thérapeutique on connaît autour de nous
des des des patients jeunes atteints de
maladie d'Alzheimer et on se on se dit
finalement ils n'ont pas leur ils n'ont
pas leur
chance merci enfin Olivier h
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
pour votre exposé très très clair et par
rapport aux valeurs que vous avez
exposé il me semble que le l'HAS a une
responsabilité très forte en terme
d'innovation mais aussi en terme de de
de prévention
d'anticipation pas seulement euh lors
des crises et donc comment vous voyez
les choses et avec l'articulation par
rapport à à la
NSM notamment sur les les les rupture en
matière de de médicaments comme la
moxyyine c'est difficile à à dire est-ce
que vous voyez un rôle là-dessus parce
que la qualité des soins elle dépend euh
de d'un certain nombre de choses et il y
a deux secteurs où il faut être en
anticipation permanente et je trouve que
là il y a quand même carence euh qu'il y
ait euh dans notre pays euh des ruptures
sur des médicaments pour les enfants euh
euh et ce qui est la santé pédiatrique
ça m'a paraît tout à fait inadmissible
cont tenu des moyens qu'on consacre à la
santé et puis la deuxième question
quelle anticipation et comment
pouvez-vous aussi est en incitation sur
tout ce qui est soins innovants je vous
remercie très bien Monsieur L si je vous
laisse répondre
à à nos quatre
sénateurs merci beaucoup
euh monsieur monsieur Chassin eu tout
d'abord
euh donc vous avez donné les les les
chiffres qui sont très très éloquents
voilà sur le le vieillissement euh de la
population et ce qui va s'en suivre en
terme de niveau de dépendance ou sur un
plan vraent de soins de prévalence de
certaines affections voilà affection
chronique donc on a devant nous un enjeu
un enjeu majeur et vous avez évoqué
notamment la question du nombre vous
avez pas prononcé le mot ratio mais vous
avez parlé de l'enjeu du du du nombre
bon euh de l'encadrement en tout cas par
les des personnes accueillis notamment
en état issement ou mais la question
peut se poser aussi à domicile bien
entendu alors par rapport à ça il y a de
de de sujets il y a est-ce qu'il faut
des ratios ou pas bon ça c'est une
question politique en cours de
discussion voilà dans dans les
différentes dans les différentes PPL en
revanche est-ce que indépendamment de la
question de savoir si on fixe un soil et
quelles sont ses conséquences sur lequel
voilà la CHS n'a pas de position en tant
que tellel moi je n'en ai pas voilà
notamment à ce stade et la question et
là je vous rejoins qui est que
évidemment si on veut donner un
accompagnement des soins de la prise en
charge de la de la perte d'autonomie qui
est du sens pour tout le monde
c'est-à-dire pour la personne accueillie
et pour les soignants aussi et parce que
voilà ce sont des personnel très attaché
évidemment à ce qu'ils font il y a une
question d'effectif il y a un enjeu
d'effectif c'est évident et saufur de ma
part dans la PPL bienvillir actuellement
dans sa rédaction actuelle il y a une
mission confiée à la HS aussi en lien
avec la CNSA qui est de faire une
évaluation un référentiel sur ce
qu'implique une bonne qualité de la
prise en charge et des soins voilà donc
ça c'est ce qui est dans les tuyaux
après ce que il y a une autre étape à
franchir en terme législatif ça je je
renvoie la balle au législateur c'est un
sujet en tout cas majeur de qualité je
j'en suis j'en suis tout à fait d'accord
alors sur la la question des
critères de de prise en charge euh par
l'Assurance Maladie donc il y a il y a
il y a vraiment et en effet qui peut
conduire à ne pas mettre à disposition
en tout cas de commercialiser son
remboursement ce qui veut dire de pas
mettre à disposition des traitements
très coûteux bonidence c'est pas mis
remboursement c'est pas mis à
disposition personne n'y a accès ou
alors chaque établissement de santé doit
les prendre en charge sur son budget et
non pas sur ce qu'on appelle la liste
enensu qui lui permet de ne pas prendre
sur son budget le coût des traitements
nécessaires au aux patients dont dont
nous parlons
donc il y a un enjeu majeur de d'accès
d'accès au traitement que fait al la CHS
elle intervient avant la décision la
décision soit d'inscription sur la liste
enensu soit d'admission remboursement et
la décision de fixation du prix c'est ce
sont les pouvoirs publics c'est le soit
le gouvernement c'est le le le
gouvernement qui la qui la prend ou le
CEPS nous on est sur l'évaluation de
deux points quel est services médical
rendu est-ce que le médical ment est
utile intéressant et quelle est
l'amélioration du service médical rendu
est-ce qu'il a une valeur ajoutée par
rapport à ce qui existe et c'est en
effet l'avis scientifique de la chaise
sur ces deux points qui va ensuite
conditionner
voilà qui va en tout cas être la base
sur laquelle le décideur va décider pour
les médicaments dont vous parlez l'enjeu
c'est notamment l'inscription sur la
liste enensu à l'hôpital aujourd'hui la
liste enens donc qui permet encore une
fois à un hôpital de d'administrer un
traitement sans que ça vienne grever son
budjet par ailleurs l' list enu elle est
réservée aux médicaments qui ont ce
qu'on appelle une asmr au moins 4 c'est
dire qui ont une valeur ajouté au moins
mineur si par rapport à d'autres
traitements ils n'ont pas de valeur
ajoutée ce qu'on appelle une asmr 5 ils
ne peuvent pas être inscrit sur la liste
enens
donc ça suppose que l'évaluation et ça
la HS si aelle c'est sa mission soit
rigoureuse parce que selon la conclusion
bien entendu on peut ou non avoir une
inscription sur la liste en su donc mise
à
disposition spécifique une mise à
disposition effective des des patients
donc ça c'est un sujet en effet euh
extrêmement euh extrêmement important
euh je je tiens juste à attirer votre
attention sur deux évolutions récentes
d'ailleurs bah que vous que vous avez
que vous avez voté et qui voilà
demanderont à être évalué en terme
d'accès à ce type de traitement c'est
d'abord la euh possibilité c'est l'accès
précoce la possibilité d'un accès
précoce qui pour certaines molécules
innovantes notamment en oncologie est
une réalité je dire la plupart des
décisions d'AC précoce prise par la
Haute Autorité de santé ça porte sur de
l'oncologie donc l'accès précoce c'est
une manière d'avoir un remboursement du
médicament qui ne greffe pas le budget
des hôpitaux et une autre innovation
juridique qui est devant nous puisque
c'est dans laall FSS pour 2024 il faut
attendre voilà qu'elle soit qu'elle soit
promulguée c'est la possibilité au terme
de l'accès précoce si au terme de
l'accès précoce la Commission de la
transparence de l'HAS estime qu'g
regarde des données disponibles on est
toujours dans l'absence de preuve d'une
valeur ajoutée donc toujours en asmr 5
et ben la loi va permettre un accès
précoce maintenu dans certains cas si la
HS n'est pas certaine qu'il y a pas de
valeur ajoutée mais qu'elle pense que
des données complémentaires peuvent le
cas échéant conduire à porter un autre
regard donc l'accè précoce prolongé ça
répond à une partie ça répond pas à tout
he mais ça répond une partie de ce de ce
sujet il faut le mettre en œuvre et ça
sera ferit dans les prochains mois si la
loi est promulguée mais je vois pas
pourquoi sur ce pointl il y aura centure
de conseil constitutionnel he
je je ne le vois pas sur Alzheimer et
les les nouveaux traitements dont vous
faites part aux
États-Unis je fer je ne sais pas où on
en est pour être je ferai le point à mon
arrivée sur ces travaux mais s'ils
arrivent dans la HS ils seront évalués
ils ser évalués donc sur les notamment
les traitements Anticor monoclonaux qui
sont une des révolutions thérapeutiques
récentes donc si ils arrivent la Chae
les évaluera
voilà le plus rapidement possible et
après ils peuvent arriver ils peuvent
arriver par une des voies rapides dont
j'ai parlé comme l'accès précoce euh sur
la question des ruptures euh sur la
question des ruptures de alors des
ruptures de de stock ou
d'approvisionnement parce que quand un
médicament n'arrive plus au patients
dans les pharmacies d'officine ou dans
les pharmacies hospitalière il peut y
avoir deux raisons soit c'est
l'industriel qui n'en a plus parce qu'il
y a eu un problème industriel parce
qu'il a des des stratégies commercial au
niveau mondial qui font que la France
n'a plus accès au au médicaments puis a
les ruptures d'approvis
certaines pharmacies en on avec des gros
stocks et et d'autres pas bon donc il y
a C ces deux problématiques qui peuvent
conduire à ce que vous à ce que vous
indiquez alors après sur les ruptures je
vais être franc c'est pas du tout pour
bter en touche parce que c'est un sujet
majeur c'est avant tout une
responsabilité du ministère et de la NSM
voilà qui sont dessus voil qui sont
dessus parce que le phénomène tend à
s'accroître le phénomène touche comme
vous parliez de de laamoxiciline des des
traitements qume très courants des
traitements absolument basique
absolument basique donc c'est c'est un
sujet majeur qu'est-ce qu'elle peut
faire la HS la HS ce qu'elle peut faire
c'est d'envoyer des alertes au
prescripteur c'est de leur dire en ce
moment et elle le fait elle l'a fait sur
la mine par exemple il y a en ce moment
il y a une tension particulière donc
vigilance dans la prescription on on
sait qu'il y a problème de
surprescription des antibiotiques et
d'ailleurs des il y a des évolutions qui
visent à permettre de ne plus prescrire
d'antibiotique sur des infections qui
sont virales voilà et non pas
bactériennes avec les test rapide
orientation diagnostique les nouvelles
compétences données aussi aux
pharmaciens récemment notamment en
matière d'engine ou de cystit donc ça ça
répond pas à votre sujet mais en tout
cas il y a une sensibilité à la
pertinence de la pression d'
antibiotique et une manière de réduire
la pression pour les patients qui en ont
vraiment besoin c'est et ça c'est le
boulot de la HS en effet de d'alerter
plus efficacement les prescripteurs
quand il y a une tension alors après il
y a une difficulté pratique c'est
comment les alerte la HS elle communique
l'outil au Quotidien du Médecin c'est
pas d'aller tous les matins même si je
le souhaiterais sur le site de la CHS
pour voir les messages le médecin il
traite ses ses patients et ça lui
demande déjà beaucoup de temps en
revanche il a devant lui un logiciel ce
serit que le logiciel lui disent alerte
alerte et c'est pour ça que la HS elle
relaye des systèmes
euh informatiqu des systèmes d'aide à la
décision en matière de médicament qui
sont des des petits modules
informatiques mais il faut que l'éditeur
le mette faut que l'éditeur prenne ce
que fait la HS et le mette dans son
logiciel et là su là HS a des moyens
d'incitation elle a pas de moyens de
contrainte la moyen d'incitation c'est
la certification des logiciels d'aide à
la prescription notamment donc intégrer
les alertes de ce type là c'est une
obligation pour les logiciels certifiés
mais la certification est facultative la
France voulait une certification
obligatoire mais ça se hetait au droit
de l'Union européenne la Cour de justice
ne l'a pas
permis merci Jean solul souhaitait
intervenir
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur
bonjour Mo je souhaite souiterais vous
poser une question sur l'évaluation des
établissements sociaux et
médicauxsociaux dont l'entrée en vigueur
c'est c'est effectué en 2022 sur la base
d'un
référentiel unique composé de 157
critères il y a environ surérant de ma
part 40000 structures à évaluer nous en
sommes aujourd'hui à une évaluation de
structures comment pensez-vous donc en
tout cas finaliser l'évaluation de ces
établissements qui doit se dérouler tous
les 5 ans sachant que vous avez à votre
disposition aujourd'hui 118 organisme
évaluateur merci je vous laisse
répondre alors là monsieur le sénateur
vous s savez plus que moi en terme de
chiffres donc je je vous remercie de de
de m'avoir donné ce ce ce point
d'actualité je ne peux pas vous répondre
donc je vous propose de vous donner des
éléments écrits de réponse sur le
calendrier de de déploiement effectif
voilà oui très bien on sera preneur
d'ailleurs l'information nous
intéressera intéressera la Commission on
sera preneur de de ce retour mais c'est
il y a un changement d'échelle parce que
les établissements de santé c'est à peu
plus de 2000 là on est sur 40000 vous
avez tout à fait raison alors après
c'est pas une évaluation que fait la HS
en première ligne vous l'avez rappelé he
c'est les organismes accrédités par le
kofrac voilà par le COFRAC une des un
des contact puisqu'on parlait de
d'ouverture et de partenariat tout à
l'heure un des contacts que je prendrai
dès mon arrivée c'est le directeur g du
kofrac voilà parce que on a partenariat
qui est important notamment dans ce
champ-là très bien merci beaucoup en
tous les cas merci monsieur le Président
merci pour vos explications voilà nous
allons continuer de commission voilà on
sera amené à se retrouver forcément dans
nos relations entre la Commission et la
CHS merci beaucoup mon merci
beaucoup
bien mes chers collègues nous allons
reprendre not